l'écu est mort vive l'euro les quinze
réunis en sommet à madrid ont en effet
décidé de baptiser euros la future
monnaie unique européenne qui devrait
entrer en circulation le 1er janvier
2002 prochaine étape cruciale de l'union
monétaire la sélection des pays qui
auront le privilège de monter dans le
premier train de la monnaie unique
en principe le 1er janvier 99 à madrid
pour france 2 philippe sassier c'est une
journée historique
historique parce que en 2002 vous
pourrez chiffonné j'étais surveillée il
aurait été remplacé par leur haut
historique parce que à madrid on a
choisi le nom de la monnaie unique est
définitivement le scénario de passage à
cette monnaie le 1er janvier 1999
les pays acp demi au club de la monnaie
unique gèleront les parités de leur
monnaie les citoyens n'utiliseront pas
cette monnaie pour payer leur baguette
de pain leur loyer ou leur impôt ah ben
2002 ni dès 1999 les états s'en
serviront notamment pour émettre leurs
emprunts une décision importante pour
affirmer la confiance dans la monnaie
nouvelle a madrid c'est la confiance
dans l'europe et le marché unique qui a
été rappelé c'est le facteur de
stabilité dont nous avons besoin donc
l'europe marché unique cesse de redouter
le désordre monétaire en son sens
l'europe a donc bien descendu l'escalier
de madrid
l'équipe fera partie du club monnaie
unique les membres seront choisis selon
les fameux critères de maastricht tu est
ici budgétaires notamment examen de
passage au début de 1998 on est enfin
sorti des ambiguïtés reste une
incertitude la situation économique en
europe dont la détérioration pourrait
rendre plus difficile la marche vers la
monnaie unique